American women elected to Congress is
nothing less than an attempt by an ally
of the United States to suppress our
ability to do our jobs as elected
officials but this is not just about me
Netanyahu's decision to deny us entry
might be unprecedented for members of
Congress but it is the policy of his
government when it comes to Palestinians
this is the policy of his government
when it comes to anyone who holds views
that's ruined the occupation a policy
that has been edged on and supported by
Trump's administration that's because
the only way to preserve unjust policy
is to suppress people's freedom of
expression freedom of association and
freedom of movement my colleague and I
are not the only ones who are being
denied the right to see for ourselves
the reality on the ground on the West
Bank the Netanyahu government for
example is currently trying to deport or
Marsha kir a human rights worker with
Human Rights Watch because he has
reported on human rights conditions in
the West Bank and Gaza last year the
Netanyahu government refused entry to
American citizen Katherine Frank Frank
and my friend Finn's Warren who had
arrived on a human rights mission all of
these actions have nothing to do nothing
to bring us closer to peace in fact they
do the opposite they maintain the
occupation and prevent a solution to the
conflict
fortunately we in the United States have
a constructive role to play
we give Israel more than three million
dollars in aid every year this is
predicated on their being an important
ally in the region and the only
democracy in the Middle East but
nying visit - duly elected members of
Congress is not consistent with being an
ally and denying millions of people
freedom of movement or expression or
self-determination is not consistent
with being a democracy we must be asking
as Israel's ally the Netanyahu
government stop the expansion of
settlements on Palestinian land and
ensure full rights for Palestinians if
we are to give them aid these are not
just my views these are the views held
by the range of experts peace advocates
on this issue we know Donald Trump would
love nothing more than to use this issue
to put Muslims and Jewish Americans
against each other the Muslim community
and the Jewish community are being other
dand made into the boogeyman by this
administration but but as we will hear
today people of all different faiths are
coming together to speak up against the
status quo in the region I'm grateful
for the Solidarity shown by so many of
my colleagues in Congress I understand
and appreciate the calls for members to
avoid traveling to Israel until Rasheeda
and I are allowed to go without
condition but it is my belief that as
legislators we have an obligation to see
the reality there for ourselves
we have a responsibility to conduct
oversight over our governments foreign
policy and what happens with the
millions of dollars we send in aid so I
would encourage my colleagues to visit
meet with the people we were going to
meet with see the things we were going
to see here the stories we were going to
hear we cannot we cannot let Trump and
ten yahoo succeed in hiding the cool
reality of the occupation from us so I
call on all of you to go the occupation
is real barring barring members of
Congress from seeing it does not make it
go away we must end it together now it's
with honor that I introduce my sister
Ishita Talib who has been so brave and
resilient and someone who has deep
connections to the region and someone
who I would have loved to met to have
met her City Ashida Talib thank you so
much to my dear friend and colleague
congresswoman Ella Hana Omar for
inviting me to her district to join you
all today I am incredibly thankful for
her leadership and strength through all
she has been dealing with as a woman of
color in Congress I don't know how she
does it
sometimes but the outpouring of support
we have received from our constituents
and supporters across the country shows
us how important it is to keep fighting
for justice today's today reps Omar and
plus K and I were supposed to be on a
congressional trip and delegation to the
Palestine and Israel and such
delegations are common occurrence for
members of Congress earlier this month
in fact 71 other members of Congress
traveled to Israel seemingly without
incident what is not common occurrence
as members of Congress being barred from
entering a country on these fact-finding
missions unless they agreed to strict
set of rules curtailing their rights are
being required to submit their
itineraries for stop by stop a pre
approval history does have a habit of
repeating itself I learned this week
that a former member of Congress
congressman Charles C Diggs jr. was
denied entry into apartheid South Africa
in 1972 he was also the representative
for the 13th congressional district in
Michigan I was born and raised in the
beautiful Detroit
where many of my african-american
teachers taught me about the realities
of oppression and justice and the need
to speak up and take action growing up
in a city that has been at the center of
many social justice movements for civil
rights labor rights and equality and
absorbing those lessons has shaped Who I
am today
and drives me to push for peace and
justice for the Palestinian and Israeli
people as a young girl visiting
Palestine to see my grandparents and
extended family I watched as my mother
had to go to dehumanizing checkpoints
even though she was a United States
citizen in proud American I was there
when my city was to a terrible car
accident and my cousins and I cried so
she could have access to the best
hospitals which were in Jerusalem I
remember shaking with fear when
checkpoints appeared in the small
village of Bethel and Foca tanks and
guns everywhere I remember visiting East
Jerusalem with my then husband and him
escorting escorted off the bus although
he was a United States citizen just
social security forces could harass him
all I can do as my city's granddaughter
as as the granddaughter of a woman who
lives in occupied territories to elevate
her voice by exposing the truth the only
way I know how as my Detroit Public
Schools teachers taught me by humanizing
the pain of oppression our delegation
trip included meetings as Israeli
veterans who were forced to participate
in military occupation they also
desperately want peace and
self-determination for their Palestinian
neighbors they could have shed light
into in justices of raids shootings
demolitions in child detention the
delegation would have seen firsthand why
walls are destructive not productive
they could have asked the people in
Bethlehem how walls cut people off away
from economic opportunities from a way
to live and do psychological damage that
lasts forever
I can do as her granddaughters help
humanize her and the Palestinian
people's plight I know that when we can
finally see them as deserving of human
dignity everyone who lives there will be
able to live in peace it is unfortunate
that Prime Minister Netanyahu has
apparently taken a page out of Trump's
book in even direction from chump to
deny this opportunity and yes while
folks are shocked that this happened to
us but today we will hear from folks who
help show the reality for many who have
been barred from going to into Israel
not to be even able to reach the
Palestinian people they are fellow
Americans who cannot visit their
families or their loved ones they should
be deep in all of us should be deeply
disturbed all of us Americans should be
deeply disturbed and with that I thin
thank you so much to my colleague
congresswoman Ileana Omar for helping
humanize the Palestinian people Thank
You Waseda next we will hear from lana
bur wacky Palestinian American and a
Minnesota resident who has never been
able to return to her family's homeland
of Palestine Thank You Ilhan hello thank
you two representatives Ilhan Omar and
Rasheeda slave for inviting me to speak
today I was asked to share some of my
personal story I'm Lana Barkawi
I'm the daughter of Palestinian
immigrants to this country I live in
Minneapolis with my husband and my two
children and although I am Palestinian I
have never been able to visit Palestine
my story is like that of so many people
who live in the Diaspora caused by the
occupation of Palestine by Israel
Palestine is a home I have never seen
and one that I longed to see about 25
years ago I was a college student
visiting family in Jordan with my mother
father and sisters we were considering
taking a side trip to visit the occupied
West Bank
a visit that would include seeing for
the first time my father's family's
village called vodka a small town near
the city of Nablus baba it's the word at
the heart of my last name but are we we
are the people of vodka incidentally
this is such a common Palestinian thing
that no matter how long your family has
been living in exile your Palestinian
identity is strong other Palestinians
you meet will want to know what town is
your family from are you able to visit
if you can go you should it's beautiful
implicit in these questions is a longing
for our people to know our homeland and
a hope that we can someday return back
to that summer 25 years ago ultimately
we did not attempt to visit Palestine as
I mentioned we were in Amman Jordan and
we would have we would have tried to
cross into West the West Bank at a
bridge crossing that spans the Jordan
River until under Israel excuse me under
Israel's laws the decision to allow or
to deny our entry would have been made
by a heavily armed Israeli soldier we
would have been at their mercy making
ourselves vulnerable to the occupying
state of Israel ultimately we did not
attempt to visit and I have to say I was
quite disappointed at the time I was a
college student reckoning with my
identity trying to reconcile everything
I knew about my loving family and our
close-knit community of Palestinian and
other Arab friends in the United States
balance all of that against the menacing
images of Palestinians that constantly
saw on the news and in Hollywood I
wanted so badly to visit Palestine and
see it all for myself it was my parents
decision not to attempt the visit not to
attempt to enter Israel my father talked
about our safety he did not want to put
me and my two sisters in harm's way
we knew the stories about what happens
to Palestinians when they attempt to
enter Israel the indignities and the
fear that Israeli soldiers have the
power to put them through since that
summer I have come to understand
decision of my parents in a deeper way
that beyond the truth of their concern
for our safety there was a more
fundamental truth my father could not
bring himself to be in a position where
an Israeli soldier is a person in
control of his entry into his homeland
there is an enduring trauma that he and
my mother live they live in exile from
Palestine from Baba and from my mother's
family's ancestral home in Yaffa and to
have the decision of our entry in the
hands of an Israeli soldier was too
great a psychic English to bear this
pails of course in comparison to the
brutal life under occupation that
millions of Palestinians face on a daily
basis
representative Omar is my congresswoman
and I am indebted to her and to
representative Slade for having the
courage to bring the cruel and racist
occupation of Palestine by Israel into
the national conversation the
dispossession and displacement of
Palestinians is a human rights issue
it's an issue of injustice of justice as
US citizens representatives of Amar and
play should be free to visit Israel a
country that calls itself a democracy to
learn for themselves how the United
States annual military and financial aid
of three billion dollars are spent they
should be free to defend US citizens
rights to financially resist Israeli
policies by participating in the
peaceful boycott divestment and
sanctions movement a movement inspired
by the effective campaign that
dismantled the apartheid system in South
Africa a few decades ago representative
Talib should be free to visit her
elderly grandmother her City for Israel
to deny a family visit or to make it
conditional is truly inhumane traveling
learning resisting visiting family these
are freedoms that we think we have as
citizens of the United States freedoms
that should be upheld by our democracy
and by that of Israel if it were the
true democracy it claims to be in my
day-to-day life I have the privilege to
work with Arab and other South West
Asian and North African artists poets
and filmmakers making space for their
Sasori work in a culture that is
preoccupied with marginalizing and
silencing our community I'd like to end
by reading a poem by the Palestinian
American poet Lena hi left tufa upon
arrival you will need to state the
reason for your visit
don't say because I want to walk down
old roads and caress stone walls the
color of my skin you will need to state
the reason for your visit
don't say because olives are ready for
harvest and I will coax the fruit from
the trees press it into liquid gold you
will need to state the reason for your
visit
don't say because my parents house still
sits empty on a bluff overlooking the
sea the green shutters my grandfather
had just painted remain sealed shut and
the army listed the properties owners as
absent 'yes you will need to state the
reason for your visit
don't say because i am carrying prayers
in my suitcase for people who wait and
i'll unfold them embroidered linens a
verse and spread them out across the
land thank you thank you Lana
I did get a book of poems from Lena just
recently in Seattle so we were both
visiting and I remember reading on the
plane right back home and crying and
everyone sort of staring at me like a
crazy person
next we will hear from amber Harris a
Minnesota resident who's married to a
Palestinian and was denied entry herself
for we she will talk about the impact of
the travel restrictions amber hello
thank you for having me letting me tell
my story my name is Amber Harris I am a
Jewish US citizen and I'm married to a
Palestinian from the West Bank with an
American Palestinian son my story has
multiple beginnings I'm gonna start
where the real struggle really began
after my husband and I got engaged in
2015 we were forced to go back to
Palestine because he had a j-1 visa and
it had ended everything was fine on my
first time I went in because I was a
Jewish American and so it was easy just
to go and in visit Israel during my
three-month stay in the West Bank my
husband and I got legally married and
the Palestine Authority informed us that
for Israel to give me my spousal visa
visa we had to leave and come back so we
got married and left for a honeymoon for
about two weeks and upon return I was
held interrogated for 10 hours by the
Shin Bet the Israeli Security Agency my
marriage documents were almost thrown
away and I was humiliated
during my interrogation they found my
Twitter social media and forced me to
open my facebook they yelled at me for
being a human rights activist an
environmentalist but was not told why
I'm being held but it was obvious um
after dismissal I was told I was a
threat to the State of Israel and a
force assigned documents in Hebrew
saying I was banned for 10 years
because my husband was not allowed to
come with me back to the US because of
visa stuff he couldn't get a visa I was
forced to say immediate goodbye to him
turn around at the border and go back to
the US not knowing when I'd see him
again but because I am privileged I have
access and that we are able to get a
Jewish Israeli lawyer it took about four
months to help us get a solution to this
and basically they came back and said
that I can attempt to come back by they
would want to reintegrate me confiscate
and search all of my belongings my
electronics open my social media and
asked for a security deposit they might
ask for a security deposit averaging ten
thousand a twenty two thousand USD which
they would give back if I left we were
forced to borrow money for my family
which is a privilege within itself and I
returned again and was held in the Albee
bridge for six hours and eventually was
again to a shinbei officer he taunted me
trying to figure out ask me why I was
banned and I didn't know cuz we I wasn't
told my lawyer was never told he
eventually said it was because I've
participated in violent riots and
protests I was confused and trying to
figure out what where he was coming from
but he shushed me and told me that I'm
gonna be allowed into the West Bank this
time but I'm under surveillance and I
believed them so I was I was allowed but
I was only a lot I was not allowed into
Israeli proper I was only allowed into
West Bank so his West Bank only visa and
the only conclusion I can come up with
all of this is that they were punishing
me for my activities in the protests of
Ferguson Missouri I was punished for the
freedom of speech in my own country and
since then I faced hurdles and
restrictions in entering the West Bank
and getting my visa and I want to make
this clear that my story is not unique
representin mert rep all omar rep Talib
Lana's story and so many are we're not
unique mine ends in a positive note
because of my privilege as a Jewish
white American but there's but these
restrictions touch everyone I know
hundreds of stories of other woman who
are people of color Muslims especially
Palestinian who may never be allowed to
return solely for the identities that
they hold Israel is denying US citizens
for their race religious beliefs as
myths ethnicity and ultimately for the
political activity it's in the u.s. the
time is now for us all to stand up as
Americans to our four fellow citizens
being denied basic human international
rights based on freedoms that exist
within our country
I want to thank rep Omar and play for
giving us this opportunity for speaking
out and being strong because it's people
like them and actions like these that
make a future that my Palestine son can
return and will always have a home to
return to and thank you for letting me
tell my story
Thank You Emperor and now let me
introduce current Herman moth the
executive director of the Jewish
Community Action thank you my name is
Karen watts and I'm the executive
director of Jewish Community Action we
organize Jews statewide here in
Minnesota for racial and economic
justice as Jews around the country in
places like Michigan and New York and
South Carolina are organizing alongside
other communities for immigrant rights
for criminal justice reform for access
to health care and affordable housing
right here as Americans we recognize
that our identities have been weaponized
to other us to divide us from our
likeliest allies and to weaken our
collective movements for justice we
recognize and resist the way that our
community's values and diversity have
been flattened and erased by a president
and administration who seek only to use
us as pawns in attacks against his
political opponents our community has
been used as a tool by those pretending
to be concerned with our safety to
undermine the Solidarity that we know is
needed in order to achieve justice and
we recognize and resist the way that the
same has been done to our Muslim
neighbors and we stand with them and
against the Islamophobia and racism
that's being wielded against them our
oppression and our resistance are both
intertwined we have been pitted against
each other our communities target
targeted and our identities weaponized
by those who have never stood with us we
have been dehumanized in service of a
white nationalist agenda and our
greatest power in resisting that is in
our solidarity the president and this
administration have engaged in a
calculated campaign to label us all as
something other than Americans tribal
above all else to define our identities
for us and to pigeonhole us to tell us
what issues we care about and to tell us
who our enemies are while defending the
actions of neo-nazis while running ads
and raising money with anti-semitic
language while lifting up the leadership
of members of Congress who actively
target us they want to co-opt our
freedom define our oppression and then
use it to turn us against each other but
we will not turn away from one another
we
stand together not just for our own
safety and survival but in pursuit of
justice and peace everywhere thank you
thank you Karen and lastly we will hear
from Rosa DeLuca from the if not now
movement my name is Rosa Drucker I'm
here as a constituent of congresswoman
Omar and I'm here as a young Jew my
Jewish values call me to defend the
freedom and dignity of all people it is
because of these values that I organize
with if not now a movement of American
Jews working to end our community's
support for the Israeli military
occupation over millions of Palestinians
the situation may be complex but it is
not complicated the occupation is a
daily nightmare for those who live it
and a moral disaster for those who
support it what we saw this past week
demonstrates Israel's desperation to
hide the realities of the occupation
from us Palestinians are denied access
to medical care education Economic
Opportunity and freedom of movement the
Israeli government receives billions of
dollars from the u.s. annually to
enforce this cruel regime when the
Israeli government denies entry to our
democratically elected members of
Congress they show us that they have
something to hide when American
politicians try to silence Ilhan Omar
and Rasheeda Talib they are complicit in
supporting the occupation when political
leaders peddle hate and so mistrust it
impacts us right here in Minnesota where
we have seen an increase in hate crimes
when the political right tells Jews to
fear progressive leaders like Ilhan Omar
inertia Talib they are weaponizing
anti-semitism for their own gain I
refuse to let my Jewish identity be used
as a tool to incite Islamophobia I
reject the narrative that
anti-occupation means aunty Jew all of
us should
and Human Rights for Palestinians I
stand by my congresswoman in demanding
accountability from the Israeli
government I stand by her in the face of
racist Islamophobic attacks by those who
seek to pit my Jewish community against
Muslims that strategy will not work we
know that the real threat to our
communities is white nationalism the
same ideology that motivates
anti-semitism motivates Islamophobia it
is only by standing together against
these attacks that we can build a better
world thank you so much Thank You Rosa
and thank you all for being here in
solidarity with us I think before we
open up for questions I just wanted to
say what often gets lost in in this
conversation is is the fact that our
work in uplifting all marginalized
voices is historically documented and
you know there isn't really anyone here
that we have not done work with and
Rashidah talks about the beautiful
Detroit community that she represents
the beautiful blackest but I also
represent Minneapolis the heart of every
progressive movement
and we did start the labor rights we
died for the labor rights movement right
and so and so it is just such an honor
to be not serving with you only because
we are the first two Muslim women to
serve but because we also represent
people who understand and value that
this particular fight we are waging on
behalf of all of oppressed people around
the world so we'll take few questions we
have to get to a town hall in a little
bit so the reaction in in my district
has been an overwhelming outcry and
condemnation of the particular action
that's been taken by the Netanyahu
administration and the urging of our
presidents I mean people really are
appalled in many ways people feel like
when you are a United States citizen
forget the fact that we are members of
Congress when you are the United United
States citizen that your president your
ambassadors your State Department works
on your behalf they defend you and fight
for your right to to freedom of speech
the freedom of movement and and to have
an administration and a president and an
ambassador that is not doing that puts
fear in many people's hearts they can't
trust if they found themselves abroad or
or were thinking you know someone was
refusing them a visa that their country
would fight for them Rashidah earlier
talked about Congressman Diggs who was
denied a visa to enter then apartheid
South Africa the United States
government our ambassador a State
Department our president fought to make
sure that he got that visa and he did go
and so for for us this isn't right
everything is beyond us and there are a
lot of people who currently feel like
what is taking place is going to have a
larger impact on on them you've heard
from Jewish members of my constituency
we've we had a really wonderful meeting
before I took my trip to get an insight
of what kind of questions they wanted me
to ask what they were interested in me
learning and how they wanted a check
back in to happen after I'd returned and
we've heard from you know almost every
single Jewish organization here in my
district who issued statements many of
the Jewish leaders in in the in my
district and in in Rashida's as well
have been raising their voices many of
our Jewish colleagues in in Congress
have have reached out and have issued a
statement in condemnation this is not
and this is not an issue where there are
some people who agree with with this
action that's being taken everyone
understands as do the elected members of
Congress who do appropriation who are
taking a vote in in regards to what our
foreign policy looks like in that region
that we should have access to see it for
ourselves and many of my colleagues and
constituents from the first day I got
elected have been urging me to go see
things for myself to reserve judgment
until I did and this is what we were
embarking on and we don't get to have
that opportunity at the moment
there was yes that's a really good
question we we've had colleagues that
are senior members some of them have
served multiple terms actually told us
about the organization and because we
asked or you know we're not the ones who
chose the organization a u.s. foundation
us-based sponsor organization
organization chosen but I was told by a
number I think there was five members of
Congress that actress in 2016 that was
sponsored by the same organization so
we're all so taken aback and learned
from everybody else that there were some
issues regarding it again I think
especially a lejano Marv and I are
extremely careful embedding because
there is a close eye in policing of our
actions that is so much more weighted on
us than any other members and so we're
very careful but when you know members
from the Congressional Progressive
Caucus that both the she and I are
extremely active and have gone to a
similar trip almost similar agenda we
were as taken aback as you are that
people are now questioning that I think
these are just distractions into the
fact that this had nothing to do really
with the agenda or these other issues
because members of Congress have gone
have many of these organizations
including breaking the silence Amnesty
International a number of these
organization era these are all
incredibly internet great international
organizations both run by Israelis and
Palestinians together that are that
we're both meeting with us
the the I think the focus is there's
hiding of the truth and hiding that the
occupation is happening and they knew us
setting foot there would basically bring
attention to something that many of us
feel is very much against international
human rights
I spoke to my family and I think my
grandmother said it beautifully when she
said I'm her off food ice food in Arabic
means her bird and she said I'm her
dream manifested I am her free bird so
why would I come back and be caged and
bow down when my election rolls her head
up high gave her dignity for the first
time and so through tears at three
o'clock in the morning we all decided as
a family that I could not go until I was
a free American United States
congresswoman coming there not only to
see my grandmother but to talk to
Palestinian and Israeli organizations
that believed that my grandmother
deserved human dignity as much as anyone
else does so it is something that I
struggled with and I talked to sister
had a sister lejano Maher a little bit
about it is a piece of you that gets
broken especially when I grew up here
and I grew up in the most beautiful
blackest city in the country where you
don't let anybody tell you you're less
than or humiliate you solely based on
your faith or your ethnicity and as the
United States congresswoman I could not
do that to my grandmother what I what I
tell Rashida all the time is that you
don't ever allow people to enjoy your
tears I say that all the time there are
so many people invested in our pain in
our struggle in seeing us broken down
and the one thing that is important to
me more than anything as we fight for
the most merchants marginalized people
is that we have our internal liberation
carry us to external liberation and
there is no way now I told Russia that
before you send that letter you should
have called me
there is no way that we are ever ever
going to allow people to tear us down to
see us cry not you know out of pain to
ever make us feel like our certificate
is less than theirs so we are going to
hold our head up high and we are going
to fight this administration and the
oppressive Netanyahu administration
until we take our last breath
thank you all have a great day thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
not national summer
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
enemy hyundai city needs immediate real
manager sir
and it's the Peter Timmy doll enough so
need to sort of conveyed through
Savannah all like that
oui Monsieur Javert feel they have very
in the nest and mr. Hyde you be there
for sure would never see what
[Music]
the filly in Syria Nicole butcher's Nico
Bouchard get away she was premeditation
sub like justice new materials aluminum
ratchets and later
oh she knows everything yesterday night
but you know Snyder knows log data local
advocate stabbed emotional Vermeil which
padule-- I just I receive of the mod
noble family bio to the Kakutani she
chose 10 even though the pyramids
animals are totally sorry yes Lee was
mr. Bremen Naga subordinate to the
[Music]